what did you do to get better as a
writer from 10 years ago to now what do
you think it's been whether it's just
the 10,000 hours we talked about it's a
lot of it is the 10,000 I mean I'm a big
believer in that once you put in your
10,000 hours you're at a place where you
just have the confidence and you know
what you're doing and so the obstacles
that you encounter you just know how to
tackle them and so that's very different
then I think then I was 10 years ago
before I had done that but I think also
just being able to recognize your
deficiencies and for me you know when I
read a great script and I go oh my gosh
you know this is a great script
I get really excited about it what are
they doing that I'm not doing like what
can I learn from what this writer did
and so I think just constantly learning
you know and constantly reading and
constantly researching and having that
in the back of your mind all the time
that you want to get better you'll just
gravitate towards things that make you
better instead of finding that
comfortable place where you know you
know you're good at writing this so I'm
just gonna write this over and over
I think forcing yourself to stretch and
because once you do that again it's it's
a great feeling you know when you've
written something good and you've done
something you haven't done before you
then you have something that you feel
really proud of I'm wondering what
scripts those are do you have one off
the top of your head that you looked at
it was like wow I wish I had written
that or I want to do something it
happens all the time like I can't think
of like a specific one that's just come
out but I was just speaking on a panel
and it was we were reading the first
five pages of a bunch of people scripts
and then we were critiquing them and we
didn't know the whole panel was and we
didn't know whose was whose and there
was one that I thought was great that I
really gravitated to and so the guy came
up afterward and was like would you like
to read it was my script that you liked
and I read it and I just thought it was
really fantastic he's a great writer and
I was I remember reading it and the it
was an action script and I don't
typically write action so I'm it was so
crisp and it was just moving so quickly
and I was like I just love how he's he's
structured this and how you know even on
the page the way it looks just so
conducive to what he was trying to
convey in terms of the content the I I
was like but I've got to remember so I
was as I was reading that I was
absorbing all that you know because he
may not be as far on his journey as I am
he is certainly a better action writer
than I am and so I was learning a lot
from how he he structured his and the
words he chose yeah and that's where you
were talking about earlier I'm not sure
what the word was bitterness but that's
where you get that chance to either take
it from bitterness so wow what can I
learn and how can I do something similar
yeah you can learn from everyone and
that's the thing there's so many people
who I think people just want to feel
validated so badly that they get to a
place where they're like I'm the expert
and everyone's just be listening to what
I have to say about this and that's it's
kind of crazy because yeah you may have
put your ten thousand hours and you may
be very good at what you do but you can
learn something from everything that you
read even learning what not to do but
even in in really bad scripts you'll
find these little moments where I'm like
oh my gosh that was really well conveyed
or you know so just being open to those
things and learning from other people
because people are constantly adding to
this body of work that exists in the
world and there's so much for you to be
able to read out there just you know be
open to what other people are doing I
but then again you have to love reading
so many writers don't love reading so
you know read read read read and see
what other people are doing a lot of
people want to start writing without
ever having read a script and I just I
don't understand it
are you also reading novels too or not
when I have time I don't have a lot of
time yeah but yeah when I get the chance
you know I love to read novels yeah it's
it's such a lost art I miss it too and
it's really hard in today's world
because so much amazing content is on
YouTube so we can learn it even faster
by watching a video but I miss the act
of reading and it's it's a lust it is
and even I mean I even get caught up
sometimes in reading nonfiction because
I feel like okay at least I'm learning
more than if I'm
novel but you should remember you are
learning you're learning you're by
getting caught up in it and seeing how
that writer has taken you through this
flow of their words you know you're
learning a lot by just doing that too
that you can then bring to screen
writing as well
you